[Musique]
vues d'hélicoptère cette passerelle posé
entre deux falaises semblent infimes
dans ce paysage majestueux de haute
montagne
pourtant longue de 28 m cette nouvelle
passerelle un rôle majeur au coeur du
cirque de mafate c'est ici l'unique voie
d'accès entre lille est à bours et grand
place une liaison indispensable pour les
mafate et de ses il est ainsi que pour
les randonneurs avant collègues fois le
pont du thé fait le thouars dans l'arrêt
pied mais après quand la rivière les
faubourgs gagne pas passer un ou arrive
là wormhout
c'était un problème mes pensées et un
problème parce qu'aucun pape à ses
ouailles besoin à l'eag remplacer megan
pas et grand place
une passerelle réalisé par louhannais
fait le département chef de file en
matière de gestion des espaces naturels
et des 1000 km de sentiers qui
parcourent notre territoire c'est aussi
la sécurité au niveau des mafatais parce
que c'était un passage qui était très
souvent inondée et que certains
habitants de certains pilotes se
retrouvait donc complètement enclavé
lors des fortes pluies donc il y avait
vraiment un aspect sécuritaire aussi
pour les habitants de la réunion même
s'ils vivent dans des espaces reculer
tels que le cirque de mafate c'est aussi
de de maîtriser les usages notamment la
randonnée qui est la première activité
touristique à la réunion et donc de de
favoriser une pratique qu'ils soient
contrôlés et sécurisés pour bas les
randonneurs les et tous les sports de
pleine nature l'ancien passage à gué ne
sera plus empruntées par les marcheurs
l'intégration de cette passerelle aura
nécessité l'aménagement du sentier par
les équipes des agents forestiers de
l'eau nf présents sur ces îles est la
passerelle une fois finie elle était en
l'air
elle était sur deux rives abrupte il a
fallu creuser à la pioche un sentier
d'accès et ensuite aménager des bordures
en utilisant les pierres qui étaient
dans la rivière et on a construit des
deux côtés des murets en pierres sèches
uniquement à la force des bras et avec
la qualité professionnelle de mes
collègues de mafate pour assembler ces
pierres qui sont jamais assemblé par
hasard c'est une construction une
construction artisanale et sa vente dans
quelques jours les coureurs de la
diagonale des fous et 12 ans brooke a
trahi emprunteront ce passage au dessus
du bras doucy dans leur grande traversée
[Musique]